là où ça bouge jacques perrotte à
l'antenne vous allez comprendre ici au
manoir du tourp comment françois
dourlent a réussi à faire de son procès
des anars qui fait le tour du monde
françois dourlent se joue des images ces
photos font le tour du monde sur
internet
mais ce prof de lettres et d'histoire
cherbourgeois est très heureux d'exposer
ses oeuvres sur papier au manoir du
tourp à omonville la rogue
j'ai commencé par ça en fait je me suis
fait la main les images archives avant
de faire un couteau un peu décalé et moi
ça me passionne parce que je suis prof
d'histoire et que c'est vrai que quand
les images ont été affichées en ville à
cherbourg il ya beaucoup d'élèves qui
n'était que ça leur parler vraiment
parce que un déjeuner un téléphone de on
voit le fond réelles et images
d'archivés et ça crée une sorte de pont
entre le passé le présent en fait comme
si on avait un appareil qui permet de
regarder en de passer en temps réel en
fait c'est ça ce que vous proposez avec
votre téléphone c'est une ouverture vers
soi l'imaginaire soit dans l'histoire il
ya de ça vaille est celle c'est un peu
le téléphone il sert un peu de fenêtres
pour regarder différemment le réel et
aussi j'avais l'idée parce que quand
j'étais professeur en banlieue je
connais leurs heures tous les jours
louis tous les gens qui avaient le nez
collé sur le téléphone et j'avais l'idée
aussi de ramener le score on a tous le
nez tout le temps collée sur le
téléphone était de ramener le
l'arrière-plan au même niveau que le
téléphone sur une surface plane en fait
qui fait que ça fait je sais pas je sais
pas si j'ai réussi mais le message était
de qu'on pouvait regagner son téléphone
et regarder ce qui se passait autour et
en faire quelque chose de sympa en fait
ok
et
et aussi marvel il ya disney s'intéresse
à vous comment vous avez été contacté
comment vous avez fait pour m cherbourg
comme ça aux états unis bah contacté en
fait j'ai eu un article dans le new york
times dans le times aussi time magazine
donc forcément les gens en ville ils ont
vu là bas aux états unis les articles de
m'envoyer un mail tout simplement
et c'était netflix et marvel disney ils
voulaient quoi ils vont faire quoi on à
revel m'avait demandé de faire des
fausses promotions pour un film avengers
que j'ai replacé à cherbourg d'ailleurs
il y avait une photo de hulk et replacer
et j'ai utilisé hull qui le bâtiment de
la clique était en travaux et gémit il
devant le bâtiment de la cub comme si
vous venez de le casser
et donc le bâtiment de la tuque a servi
à une campagne de pub marvel pour
avengers aux états unis donc il ya un
petit côté imposture ont fait le côté
rigolo où tous les imaginer les
américains les les fautes ont été
placardées placardées partout mais
c'était cherbourg que c'est super drôle
à la
mais parler du festival oui un petit peu
avec pour thème relaieront vous avez
parlé les auteurs non le ravin boc
auteurs oui ils seront ici san nicolas
oresme à fleury sur orne le 6l 7 février
le festival du polar
bah oui pour le festival du polar ils
écrivent tous des super super pour la
wii on va en parler on va en parler ya
pas deux si le loup y était il ne
mangerait cette table ronde au mois une
exposition interactive a de supers
galère commence à tendre harper et des
jeux des animations
c'est parti pas moyen de s'ennuyer de
galles est là où qu'est ce que tu vas
dire je veux dire c'est ça fleurit sur
roxy jusqu'au 7
et
c'est bien ouais très très bien et c'est
gratuit puisque c'est gratuit je peux y
aller là allez vas-y fille allô allô
quand oui ici cherbourg oui ici
cherbourg ici sherbrooke c'est le nom
d'un festival peut nous soirée qui aura
lieu le 6 février avec tous les artistes
locaux de cherbourg et du cotentin dans
pourquoi les avoir réunis alors nous les
avons réunis tout simplement parce qu'il
vient un vivier de talents à cherbourg
et dans le nord cotentin et également
pour fédérer un peu la scène la scène
locale à des musiques actuelles et de
vous lier leur donner l'opportunité en
une soirée
ça va durer assez longtemps apparemment
de jouer comme ça devant public dans ce
thé dansant dans cette salle contact du
vox donc alors oui tout simplement le
l'idée c'est de les faire jouer devant
un public qu'on espère nombreux et dans
des conditions les plus professionnel
possible
c'est la première fois et vous espérez
que ce festival va perdurer bien sûr
alors oui c'est la première fois on
espère également que ça va perdurer
après l'idée n'est pas uniquement de
faire une soirée c'est également de
faire régulièrement des réunions avec le
groupe et de les laisser plus ou moins
se rencontrer antoine les tentes ederer
est vraiment une scène sherbrookoise on
peut dire de musiques actuelles
exactement oui oui tout à fait bien
moins de succès on espère ici cherbourg
donc le 6 février à partir de là à
partir de 16h45 et jusqu'à minutes
et c'est au vox merci mathieu est bien
ici même à caen au porto mélo demain
soir à 21h deux groupes dont big sisters
qui sort son premier repli en reparle
dans là où ça bouge
et puis demain un spécial enfants c'est
formidable la vie demain 21h ici le
concert